foreign
kicks off this hour in Charlotte North
Carolina Stephen welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey how are you doing thank you for
having me absolutely how can we help
um yes so I am currently a full-time
student
um also have a full-time job just
finishing up my last year in school I
have around twenty thousand dollars in
student loans in 10 000 in car uh a car
loan that I have
um I was just trying to get more advice
on how to kind of handle all of that
while finishing school should I wait
till after should I start tackling this
debt now my income's pretty good
although I think after I graduate it
will be much more so I would just
calling to get some advice what's the
income now
um around 55. damn that's pretty good
it's impressive man full-time student
yeah how much time did you say you have
until you graduate
uh this is my last year okay
now go ahead George looking at your
income looking at the payments are you
able to cash flow the remainder of
school
um so I did just take out recently a
loan in order to uh finish up my summer
classes and everything that's kind of
where I have to is that part of the 20
that you mentioned
correct okay that's total okay so the
damn the damage is done there and so if
school is completely covered we could go
ahead and start to pay this off since
you aren't working full time and there's
no danger of going into more debt
I would especially depending on the type
of loan you have student loan
and uh recently I just got a raise so
after taking out that loan um I thought
it would be best to kind of put that
loan back while there's no interest on
it and just kind of pay out of pocket
since I have the remaining money to do
so that's great you say put the loan
back what do you mean by that
um so after they refunded me out for
what I was going to pay out of pocket
for uh summer part of that loan I could
just kind of pay it back to the lender
and then pay my cash uh for my whatever
I need to pay in summer cool
so if you're if you're following the
Ramsey plan your first A1 would be a
thousand dollar emergency fund do you
have that already
uh yes okay how much money do you have
beyond that
um I have around nine thousand ten
thousand dollars saved oh wow that's
great so we're about ready to Let's get
this car alone
right right that's great yeah you can do
that you could do that tomorrow
okay
it's not a joke yeah
okay take that 9k put it towards the car
you'll have 1K left and then you've got
this great income where you can start
cash flowing your debt snowball
so once you have eleven thousand dollars
to your name you can clean clean up that
car loan and still have that thousand
dollar emergency fund now we're ready to
tackle the student loan and if you can
pay that off before you graduate that
would be amazing are you able to pay off
the loan before graduation
um I think it would be uh just based off
how the Iran and stuff has gone up in
this area it would be kind of difficult
but
um I think I could okay cool stretch
goal I'm doing now you seem like a
driven guy who's ready to to clean this
up and so I just love the idea of you
graduating completely debt free with no
payments you'd be such a unicorn and
then you'd be able to save up that three
to six months in no time
right I know it's not the most extreme
situation but just watching all the
recent videos I'm like I should probably
figure out the best way to handle this
now so that's why I just want to get
some insight oh that's great Steven well
you know when it comes to extreme and
I've I've been there it can feel extreme
I mean there's people who have seven
thousand dollars in debt and it feels
like they can't breathe and so don't
don't minimize your situation and you
becoming debt free at your age is
incredible it is it is life goals I wish
I had been let that way at 19 and 20 and
21. these young cats man there's they're
smarter than that early